in this video we're going to practice
the unit circle we're going to find
trick values in radians in degrees we're
going to do s cosine tangent cosecant
secant cotangent we're going to go
through 26 examples A through Z and I
want to encourage you to pause the video
practice these problems if you can get
all these right you master the unit
circle and we're going to be uh looking
at our unit circle over here a little
bit but I encourage you to try to do it
by memory if you can so let's dive in
and let's see what we can learn here so
starting off with letter A S of
210° well how do we figure out what the
sign of 210° is well first of all we
want to think about where is that on our
unit circle we start over here at the
positive x-axis 90 180 30 more is going
to put us right here roughly okay and
wherever you end up you drop a
perpendicular to the x-axis and your
reference angle is this angle here
between the terminal Ray and the x-axis
you can see that that's a 30° angle
so what we do is we refer back to the
30° angle in our first quadrant okay and
the coordinates of this point are going
to be the same as the coordinates of the
30° uh point in the first quadrant the
only thing is in the third quadrant
because you're going left and down both
the X and the Y are negative so that's
going to be < tk3 over2 - one2 for this
point now remember the sign is the y
coordinate because remember s is
opposite over hypotenuse since the
hypotenuse is one anything divided by
one is itself so on the unit circle s is
the Y cosine is the X tangent is the Y
over the X so in this case you can see
the sign our y coordinate is going to be
-
one2 and you got it now if any of this
seems uh challenging for you check out
my master the unit circle video that I
did and I go into more depth but here
we're trying to get some good practice
in so let's go to letter B now cosine of
11 Pi 6 you can see we're switching um
uh gears here from degrees to radians so
where is 11 pi over 6 on our unit circle
sometimes what I like to do is think
about this as a mixed number it's 1 and
56 PI right so one Pi we know is like
180 plus another 56 of Pi is going to
put us right here and if I drop a
perpendicular to the xaxis I can see
that reference angle is going to be 16
Pi 16 Pi is the same as 30° again so you
can see at this point it's going to have
the same coordinates it's going to be <
tk3 /2 but - 1/2 see how we're going
down the y coordinate is negative now
we're interested in looking for the
cosine value cosine is our x coordinate
right on the unit circle so this is
going to be S < tk3 over two okay let's
look at the next one tangent of 5 pi
over 3 so I now a lot of this what I do
in my mind but we're kind of drawing it
out here just to kind of visualize but I
say to myself where is 5 pi over 3
that's like 1 and 2/3 Pi so 1 Pi is 180
plus another 2/3 of Pi 3/3 would be all
the way over to here right so 2/3 is
going to put us right here wherever I
end up I drop a perpendicular to the
xaxis and I look at that reference angle
between the terminal Ray and the x- axis
and I can see that that's going to be
1/3 Pi because this was 2/3 plus another
1/3 to get back to the xais so 1/3 Pi
I'm thinking 60° and it's going to have
these Val here at this point
comma < tk3 over2 why negative because
we're going down it's like you're going
right a half down3 over two another
little uh hint is that when I think
about this shorter leg I know it's the
1/ half leg that's 0. five the longer
leg I know is a < T3 over two leg that's
about
8687 roughly so we're interested in the
tangent the tangent the y coordinate
divided by the x coordinate well root3
over2 ided by 12 the twos are going to
cancel that's just going to give you
negative < TK 3 okay let's go to letter
D now the cosecant of 3 pi over 4
another radian one so this is like 34s
of Pi so we're going not Pi 180 but 34s
of the way that's going to put us
somewhere right about here if we drop a
perpendicular to the x-axis this is
going to have a reference angle of 1/4
Pi or you could say pi over 4 which is a
45° angle so we know the coordinates of
this Point here are going to be the same
as the one in the first quadrant < tk2
over2 < tk2
over2 but the x coordinate is going to
be negative because we're going left and
the y coordinate is going to be positive
because we're going up we want the
cosecant now s and cosecant they're
reciprocals of each other so the sign we
know is the y coordinate the cosecant is
the reciprocal of the Y so this is going
to be 2 over > two now we don't want to
leave that radical in the denominator so
we're going to rationalize it by
multiplying the top and bottom by < tk2
and so that's going to give us 2 < tk2
over 2 the 2 cancel it's just going to
beunk of two okay let's look at the next
one secant of 120° we're back to degrees
now so where is 120 we start here at the
positive xais we rotate 90 plus 30 more
it's going to put us right here at 120
drop a perpendicular to the xaxis and
remember that reference angles between
the terminal aray in the xaxis and you
can see 120 that's going to be another
60° to get back to the xaxis which means
that this point is going to have the
same coordinates as a 60° angle in the
first quadrant it's just that the x is
going to be negative since we're going
left and the Y is going to be positive
since we're going up now what are we
interested in we're interested in the
secant remember the cosine and the
secant are reciprocals of each other on
the unit circle the cosine is the x
coordinate so we're going to take take
the reciprocal of that x coordinate and
that's going to give us -2 okay now for
letter F now we've got the coent of
90° okay 90° is going to put us right
here and the coent is a reciprocal of
the tangent we know tangent is y overx
so cotangent is going to be X over y 0 /
1 is going to be equal to zero and for
letter G the sign of Pi okay Pi we know
is
180° Pi is going to be right right here
and at this point what are the
coordinates well we're going left one up
zero this is the point -1
0 and the sign we know is the
y-coordinate so at this point it's going
to be equal to zero let me erase the
Whiteboard let's continue on we're going
to go through a through z 26 examples
again see if you can pause the video and
try some of these on your own okay for
letter H now we've got the cosine of
225° so where's 225 well we're going 180
plus another 4 45 that's going to put us
right about here drop a perpendicular to
the xaxis and we can see that that's a
45° reference angle which means we refer
back to the 45 degree angle in the first
quadrant it's going to have the same
coordinates the < tk2 over2 < tk2 over2
but they're both going to be negative
because we're in the third quadrant
we're going left and down we want the
cosine which we know is the X coordin on
the unit circle so this is just going to
bek2 over 2 okay for letter I what did
you get for this one tangent of 4 pi
over 3 4 pi over 3 I think of this as
4/3 pi or 1 and 1/3 Pi so you're going
one pi plus another 13 which is going to
put us right about here drop a
perpendicular to the xaxis and you can
see that that reference angle is going
to be 1/3 Pi or pi over 3 so we refer
back to that first quadrant 30 UH 60
degree angle pi over 3 this is going to
be a 12
uhga - one2 because we're in the third
quadrant > over2 because we're going
left negative down negative and we're
interested in the tangent which the
tangent is the Y over the X when you
divide these the twos are going to
cancel and the negatives are going to
cancel this is just going to give us a
positive < of
3 okay for letter J now the cosecant of
7 pi over 4 I think of this as 1 and 34
Pi so we're going one pi plus another
34s of Pi which is going to put us
somewhere right about here you drop a
perpendicular to the xaxis and you look
at that reference angle which we went
3/4s of Pi it would take another 1/4 of
Pi to get back to the xaxis so if we
refer back to the 1/4 Pi or 45° angle
here this is going to be uh < tk2 over2
comma < tk2 over2 okay because we're in
the fourth quadrant Y is negative we
want the cosecant which is the
reciprocal of this s s is the y
coordinate if we flip that over we're
going to get -2 over < 2 which we can
rationalize and that's going to give us
-2 < tk2 over2 / two the twos are going
to cancel which is just going to give
us < TK 2 okay now for letter K the
secant of 270° so back to degrees here
270 I'm sure you're familiar with that
one that's going to put us right here
and the coordinates are 0 one now the
secant is the reciprocal of the cosine
right cosine is our x coordinate and
what you can do when you take the
reciprocal of a integer like this you
can think of it as a fraction by putting
it over one anything divided by one is
itself so the reciprocal of zero would
be like one over zero which is undefined
so that means that uh you can draw it
like that or you can write undefined
okay how about for letter L cotangent of
135 so
135 is 90 plus another 45 that's going
to put us right here we drop a
perpendicular we can see that reference
angle is a 45° angle we've already
gotten that written down here from a
previous problem we can see < tk2 over2
< tk2 over2 we want the cotangent which
is the X over The Y now anything divided
by itself is one see these are both
root2 over two but a negative divid by a
positive is going to give us a negative
one okay for letter M we've got the sign
of pi over 4 pi over 4 is one that you
I'm sure you've memorized it's right
here in the first quadrant um and you
can see that's a 45 degree s is the
y-coordinate so you can see it's going
to be just < tk2 over2 that was kind of
an easy one for us and letter N the
cosine of pi/ 6 pi over 6 is 30 remember
you can always put 180 in for pi so 180
divid 6 is 30 we want the cosine which
is the x coordinate so that's going to
be < tk3
over2 okay for letter O the tangent of
pi over 3 this is a 60° angle which is
right here and we want tangent so that's
YX the twos are going to cancel in the
denominator that's going to be > 3 over
1 which isun of
3 and for letter P we have the cosecant
of
330° which 330 is where it's almost to
360 but it's 30° short of that or shy of
that so this is a 30° reference angle
and so these are our coordinates and we
want the cosecant which is the
reciprocal of the sign which is the y
coordinate so if we take the reciprocal
of -- one2 we're going to get
-2 and for letter Q the secant of
150 150 that's not on our Circle here
yet that's 90 plus 60 more that's going
to put us right here we drop a
perpendicular to the xaxis that's a 30°
reference angle okay to get to the
x-axis we can refer back to the 30°
angle in our first quadrant which is
going to be a < tk3 over2 positive 12 uh
reason X is negative we're going left Y
is positive we're going up we're
interested in the secant which is the
reciprocal of the x coordinate because
cosin's X and see and cosine are
reciprocals so if we flip that over
that's going to give us a -2 / 3 we're
going to want to rationalize that by
multiplying the top and bottom by square
of 3 so that comes out to 2K 3 / 3 let
me erase the Whiteboard we'll do the
last last few examples and we'll get
some practice there see if you can take
a screenshot of this uh right here these
last examples and try them on your own
we'll go through them together so
starting with letter r the cotangent of
2 pi over 3 so 2 pi over 3 is like 2/3
of Pi Pi is 180 so we're going 2/3
another 1/3 would take us back to the
x-axis so that reference angle is 1/3 pi
and you can see that's going to be this
point right here that we did on our
previous problem it's negative one2 >
over two we want the cotangent which is
the X over The Y so X over y that's
going to be a
-2 ided by < tk3 over2 now we know when
we divide that's the same thing as
multiplying by the
reciprocal so you can see the twos are
canceling and then if we rationalize
this by multiplying the numerator
denominator by 3 over 3 that's going to
give us < tk3
over3 okay for letter s we've got the
sign of 5 pi over 4 that's like 1 and
1/4 Pi so we're going pi plus another
1/4 of Pi is going to put us right here
at the < tk2
over2 coordinate and we want the sign
which is the Y value so that's going to
be < tk2 over 2 okay for letter T now
the cosine of 3 pi/ 2 this is like 1
and2 Pi so we're going 1 pi plus another
half of Pi that's going to put us right
here at this point we want the cosine
which which is the x coordinate that's
going to be
zero and for U we've got the tangent of
7 piun over 6 that's like 1 and 1 16 Pi
so one pi plus another 1 16 of Pi 1 16
is like 30° that's going to put us right
at this point here we want the tangent
which is the Y overx and you can see
that was the same problem that we had
over here -2 / byun3 over2 but they were
both negative so this is just going to
come out to a positive < tk3 over3
and for letter V the cosecant of 8 pi
over 3 this is like 2 and 23 Pi so 2 pi
is all the way around plus another 2/3
is going to put us right here the
reference angle is 1/3 Pi or
60° so you can see we've got the
coordinate -2 < tk3 over2 we want the
cosecant which is the reciprocal of the
Y so that's 2 over > 3 we can
rationalize by multiplying the top and
bottom by < tk3
so that comes out to 2 3 over
3 and for letter W we have the secant of
Pi / 2 remember Pi is 180 ID 2 is 90
that's going to put us right here the
secant is the reciprocal of the cosine
which cosine is the x coordinate if we
take the reciprocal of that x coordinate
that's 1 over Z which is undefined
because we uh can't divide by zero
letter X we've got the cotangent of 225
225 is going to be 180 plus 45 more
that's going to put us right here that's
this coordinate the < tk2 over2 one
cotangent is X over y but anything
divided by itself is going to be equal
to 1 and for y we've got the S of 7 piun
over 4 which is 1 and 34 Pi so 1 pi plus
another 34 of Pi that puts us over here
at these < tk2 over2 point and S is the
y coordinate so that's going to be < tk2
over2 in the fourth quadrant Y is
negative and then for letter Z cosine of
4 pi over three that's like 1 and 1/3 Pi
so we're going 1 pi plus another 1/3 of
Pi that reference angle is 1/3 Pi or 60
we can refer back to our 60 in the first
quadrant same coordinates but X and Y
are negative being in the third quadrant
we want the cosine which is the x
coordinate and that's going to come out
to -
one2 so great job A through Z if you're
able to get these problems let me know
in the comments below how you did and if
you want more practice or you want a
better understanding of how this unit
circle Works follow me over to that
Master the unit circle video that I did
right there we'll go over there we'll
get some more practice and I'll see you
over there